LINDSAY: Good evening, everyone.
Welcome to tonight's Council on Foreign Relations
meeting.
I am Jim Lindsay, senior vice president and
director of studies here at the Council on
Foreign Relations.
I also want to welcome everyone who's joining
us via the wonders of the Internet as we livestream
tonight's lively and timely discussion.
It is my great pleasure and honor to introduce
tonight's guests.
I think you're going to learn they are both
terrific talents, and I'm very proud to be
their colleague.
First, to my immediate right is Ambassador
Robert Blackwill.
He is the Henry A. Kissinger Senior Fellow
for U.S. Foreign Policy.
Now, Bob has had an illustrious career in
public service, having held numerous and will
say distinguished foreign policy posts over
the years.
I am-beg my pardon, Bob-not going to go through
all of the posts you've had.
Let me just hit a couple of the highlights.
Bob has served for-or under five presidents.
He was U.S. ambassador to India from 2001
to 2003.
He did multiple stints on the staff of the
National Security Council, including as deputy
assistant to the president and deputy national
security adviser for strategic planning under
George W. Bush.
Between his government stints, Bob was on
the faculty at Harvard's Kennedy School of
Government for a dozen years.
He wrote a lot.
By my count, he has written, co-written, co-edited
10 books, one of them being the best-selling
book, with Graham Allison, "Lee Kuan Yew:
The Grand Master's Insights on China, the
United States, and the World."
And just this year the Indian government honored
Bob with the 2016 Padma Bhushan Award for
distinguished service of a high order.
So, congratulations, Bob.
Our other guest is Jennifer Harris.
Jen is a senior fellow here at the Council.
Before joining the David Rockefeller Studies
Program, Jen served on the staff of the National
Intelligence Council and on the policy planning
staff of the U.S. State Department, where
she was a lead architect of Secretary Clinton's
Economic Statecraft agenda.
Jen is both a Truman and a Rhodes Scholar,
quite an accomplishment.
And tonight, however, we're not here to sing
their past praises; we're here to talk about
the publication of their terrific new book,
"War by Other Means: Geoeconomics and Statecraft."
So please join me in welcoming
Bob and Jen.
(Applause.)
Congratulations, Bob, congratulations, Jen,
on the publication of the book.
BLACKWILL: Thank you.
LINDSAY: I will note that The Weekly Standard
called it "readable and lucid"-(laughter)-and-
BLACKWILL: It's better than the alternative.
(Laughter.)
LINDSAY: Oh, it's-I'd take it.
That's pretty good.
And a reviewer in the Indian Express was so
taken with the book that he urged Indian diplomats
and strategists to read it because it was
relevant to what they do.
Let's begin with the basics.
Looking at the subtitle of the book, it contains
a word that many people either may not be
familiar with, or have heard in a variety
of different contexts, and that's the word
"geoeconomics."
So I'm going to turn to you first, Bob: What
do you mean by "geoeconomics"?
BLACKWILL: Well, that turned out to be a question
that Jen and I worked hard on in the early
stages of our research.
If you, to our surprise, look in the literature
exhaustively, you find the constant use of
the term without any definition, and people,
scholars, and public policy practitioners
using the term without ever defining what
they think it is.
So we thought hard about it, and came up with
the definition which we think distinguishes
this particular discipline from others, which
is that geoeconomics is using economic tools
for geopolitical purposes.
So it's not using economic tools for economic
purposes, although those are fine, notable
objectives.
It's using these economic tools to advance
a government, a nation's geopolitical interests.
And the book is organized around that definition,
and we look at which countries are skillful
at using those instruments for geopolitical
objectives and which ones are less apt.
LINDSAY: So geoeconomics is a subset of geopolitics,
rather than something different from geopolitics?
BLACKWILL: I would say it's parallel to geopolitics.
Most-and maybe Jen would chime in; we'll see
if we even agree.
But if you look at geopolitics and you go
back to the 19th century and Mackinder and
all of that, you discover that it has a very
strong geographic orientation, and a geographic
orientation based on security, OK?
And this is a different notion, both because
technology of course has erased many of those
boundaries, but also the great strategists
from Sun Tzu forward don't usually talk about
economics as a means to geopolitical objectives.
And without giving you the punchline, the
United States for most of its history understood
the utility of these economic instruments
for geopolitical purposes, from the Louisiana
Purchase to the Marshall Plan-both of which,
of course, were dominated by geopolitical
considerations-but in more recent decades
have forgotten that historical legacy.
LINDSAY: Did you want to jump in here, Jen?
HARRIS: Sure.
In practice, a lot of people know what geopolitics
looks like when they see it.
It's more or less the way in which states
are struggling for control over territory,
often by reference to a set of geographic
factors, right: population, military, including
certain economic factors.
But where-what we're really trying to describe
is how states are pursuing those same aims,
but rather than reaching for traditional diplomatic
or military tools, they are reaching for a
whole host of economic tools.
And this can take the form of everything from
trade and investment policies that are wielded
more, again, in pursuit of certain geopolitical
aims; or certain aspects of the cyber domain,
the way in which countries are acting-
LINDSAY: So, for you, cyber as part of geoeconomics.
HARRIS: Some of it.
Some of it.
Certainly some cyberattacks that have been
state-sponsored, the goings-on in various
nuclear facilities, we don't consider that
within the realm of what we're talking about.
But where we see states taking to cyberattacks
against the banking sectors of others countries
to vent a geopolitical grievance, like we
saw in the early days of the Russia-Georgia
conflict in 2008, where some of Russia's opening
shots were cyberattacks aimed at the Georgian
banking sector, that is very much within the
realm of what we're looking at.
LINDSAY: I take it from your opening remarks,
Bob, that you came to the conclusion that
some states are good at geoeconomics and some
states aren't.
Who's really good at it?
BLACKWILL: China.
You'd have to start with China.
And as we discuss in the book at some length,
this isn't a perfect scorecard.
China doesn't always do it well.
But for two decades or so, as China became
more powerful, they have begun quite systematically
to use incentives-interest-free loans-and
disincentives-coercive measures-to affect
the geopolitical positions of other nations.
Lee Kuan Yew put it like this, which is vivid.
He said, "the Chinese say publicly all states
are equal.
But when we do something that they don't like,
they say: have you noticed the size of our
market?
And know your place; don't offend 1.2 billion
Chinese."
So they calibrate this.
If Japan does something geopolitically they
don't like, Japanese imports of automobiles
to China diminish.
If the Philippines don't act in ways in the
South China Sea that Beijing doesn't like,
Philippine fruits and vegetables rot on the-on
the docks of Chinese ports.
And so forth.
So I think they, with this enormous wealth
they now have to use, have been the most skillful-not
perfect, but skillful-in reminding other countries
that there is an economic price to pay for
geopolitical behavior that China doesn't like.
LINDSAY: So, Jen, who else makes the list
of countries that are good at geoeconomics?
HARRIS: Certainly, as Bob mentioned, China
tops that list, but China's not alone.
You know, Russia's pipeline politics I'm sure
is well-known to all of you.
But we also see Russia slapping very questionable
sanctions on Ukrainian chocolates that happen
to be owned by Petro Poroshenko months, in
fact, before we saw protester really fill
the Maidan Square.
And we also see this-you know, the Gulf countries
in 2015 alone spend some $12 billion in the
contest for favor with the new Egypt.
Just, what, last week we saw the Saudis threaten
to dump U.S. Treasury bills if, in fact, Congress
goes through with pinning liability for 9/11
on the Saudis.
So certainly, you know, China is a leading
practitioner, but by no means all there is.
There's ample examples from India, Brazil,
on through as well.
LINDSAY: OK.
Two words I haven't heard: United States.
So is that because the United States is just
mediocre at the practice of geoeconomics,
or is it bad at it?
BLACKWILL: You take this one, Jen.
HARRIS: (Chuckles.)
Well, I think it's really a forgotten or a
lost art in American statecraft.
And digging back through the history, what
actually was some of my favorite research
for the book-as someone who ran from history
in grad school and college, it's sort of cosmic
irony that this would prove to be some of
the most interesting, anecdote-filled pieces
of the project-but you really see for the-about
the first 200 years of American history, you
know, U.S. leaders quite comfortable flexing
U.S. economic muscle in pursuit of explicitly
geopolitical aims.
There certainly were-you know, the high-water
marks are pretty well-known to all of us:
the Marshall Plan.
But even, you know, things like the Louisiana
Purchase.
As much as Jefferson liked a good deal, his
main motivation was keeping the French from
gaining a foothold on the American continent,
and potentially setting a pretty young and
exhausted U.S. Army up for a confrontation
with Napoleon's troops that we probably wouldn't
win.
Even, you know-and some of the-some of the
pieces that are in some ways familiar, but
yet not, of U.S. geoeconomic statecraft, Lend-Lease
comes to mind.
Churchill once called this a declaration of
economic war, except it was one that he felt
was aimed as much at Britain as Berlin, and
he wasn't unfounded in this.
You know, the terms of what was really about
$660 billion worth of American aid that we
were lending to our allies in World War II
came at some cost.
We were unilaterally controlling the level
of British gold, and, you know, unilaterally
controlling British exports, and seeking to
rewrite the terms of the postwar order with
the U.S. interests at the center.
And none of this was lost on the British.
LINDSAY: I think a lot of people-
BLACKWILL: Could I just chime in.
One more sense the British are at issue here,
two more.
One, during the American Civil War, when the
British were tempted to be sympathetic to
the Confederacy because of their dependence
on Southern cotton, the government-the U.S.
government, the Lincoln government-told them
that if they wish to have all of their assets
in the United States expropriated, this would
be a good way to do it.
And then, of course, Suez comes to mind, in
which the United States-the Eisenhower administration-so
appalled by the British-French invasion of
Suez, threatened basically to destroy the
British pound if they proceeded.
And that was the end of the intervention that
the British were-it wasn't Eisenhower and
Dulles' general opposition to this, it was
that Harold Macmillan, who was at Number 11-he
was the finance minister to Anthony Eden-said
they can do it, and they'll do it.
And Eisenhower would have done it, because
Ben-Gurion lied to him in writing about the
Israeli involvement in this.
So we used to know how to do it.
HARRIS: And none of these are things, right,
that we can imagine our friends in the administration,
on either side of the aisle, Republican or
Democrat, really contemplating with any seriousness
today.
LINDSAY: But I would imagine a lot of people
hearing this story would say, well, wait a
second, the United States resorts to financial
sanctions, trade sanctions quite regularly.
They were used to try to bring the Iranians
to the negotiating table.
We applied them against Russia in the wake
of the Russian seizure of Crimea.
So do those not count as geoeconomics?
Or is it geoeconomics done badly?
HARRIS: So we try to be pretty upfront in
the book that we see sanctions as kind of
the exception that proves the rule.
Right now, the Obama administration has about
30 sanctions programs in place, which is more
than any other president in history, I think
more than several combined.
And it's not just a story about innovation
and quantity, these are really sanctions that
are different in kind.
But even as you have seen, you know, real
sort of progress made in the sanctions realm,
you don't see it encased within a broader
diplomatic strategy that, for instance, managed
to get the French to turn off military shipments
to Russia sooner than the seven months of
long, hard conversations that it took.
Or, you know, conversations within NATO about
what are the proper responsibilities and shared
understandings are around what is owed to
military allies when it comes to economic
coercion.
LINDSAY: What about something like the Trans-Pacific
Partnership?
There's been a lot of talk about TPP not being
solely about trade, but about trying to set
the geopolitical order in East Asia.
Is this an indication of geoeconomics getting
back on the U.S. agenda, or do you think it's
more symbolism than reality?
BLACKWILL: Well, it isn't symbolism, but it's
a matter of sequence.
And we go into it in the book in some detail.
Our analysis-and there's lots of documentation
available which supports this-is that we do
not negotiate trade agreements with geopolitical
objectives in mind.
We simply don't.
These are trade agreements negotiated by our
experts on trade, which of course are seeking
to reinforce U.S. national interests, and
make America wealthier, and open up the global
economy, and so forth.
But they are negotiated solely on trade criteria.
After they are agreed, and when administrations
have to sell these agreements to the U.S.
Congress, they suddenly recognize and assert
their geopolitical importance.
Ash Carter says that the TPP is worth one
aircraft carrier, OK?
Colin Powell made similar comments about NAFTA.
These are all made after the fact, when we're
trying to persuade the Congress-administrations
are trying to persuade the Congress to approve
them.
To put it differently, if you did imagine
that there should be geopolitical objectives
in the TPP, in the agreement, of course you
would address Chinese coercive pressure on
the nations of Asia.
Of course you would have that in the agreement,
because it's persistent and it's been relatively
effective in many cases.
There's not a word about that.
And what it demonstrates, at least in our
view, is that these able, dedicated trade
people don't consider that as an important
element in their negotiation, and there's
no one there who makes that case.
And then we do-just to finish, we look at
the history of the bureaucratic politics of
this.
And the story which Jen, who was in, as our
chairman said, the Clinton-or the Obama administration
for Hillary Clinton, working at the State
Department, the bureaucratic politics over
these decades has reduced the role of the
State Department in these trade negotiations,
partly at the insistence of the Congress.
So they're basically far at the margin of
this today.
So, negotiate them with no geoeconomic content
and sell them with a geoeconomic/geopolitical
argument is the history of these agreements.
LINDSAY: So, Jen, I take it that the clock
is running down on the administration you
worked in.
Next January we're going to get a new president.
Leaving aside whoever is going to win the
race, from your vantage point, what should
the next administration do if it were serious
about geoeconomics?
What would that look like?
HARRIS: So Bob and I sketch out a 20-point
prescription agenda in the final chapters
of the book, which I will not recount right
now.
(Laughs.)
In part because I would hope that all of you
agree with us, but reasonable minds can and
should and will differ on, you know, the particular
tacks to take.
And a lot of this is going to be fact-bound.
Our project is really less to argue a case
for what to think about the geoeconomics rules
and more to lay out a framework for how to
think about them.
And so, to me, any prescriptive agenda would
have-whatever the particulars of it-would
have four basic ingredients.
One, I think you do need a common reference
point, a common conceptual framework with
a clear definition that allows us to be clear
with ourselves, bureaucratically, and clear
with our allies.
In order to call out geoeconomic coercion
when it's happening to our allies in Asia,
we need to know what it looks like.
And so I think that's point one.
Point two would be to really begin to work
this into the bloodstream of some of our alliances.
Our relationship with Europe is a great example.
You know, NATO is the closest military alliance
probably the modern world has ever known,
and yet we remain one of four or five countries
that has not moved beyond very basic most-favored-nation
status with the EU in trade terms.
We lack any economic counterpart for what
NATO represents on the security side, even
as it's very clear that when Russia wants
to, you know, flex geopolitical muscle, it
is reaching for these economic tools, as we've-as
has been put on pretty clear display in Ukraine.
So I would want to see us begin to prioritize,
you know, certain geoeconomic responses within
some of our closest sort of security relationships.
Third, resources.
You know, this in part a dollars and-
LINDSAY: Money.
HARRIS: This is, in part, a dollars-and-cents
issue; $713 million-one of my favorite numbers
that I have been quoting a lot these days-Monday
through Wednesday in Afghanistan.
And so when it comes to arguing, you know,
for what we could do for Ukraine in terms
of giving that country a viable economic foundation
or how we might begin to steel our allies
in Asia against the kind of geoeconomic coercion
that Bob is talking about, our entire aid
envelope for Ukraine last year, I believe,
was about $340 million-less than half of Monday
through Wednesday in Afghanistan.
So it is, in part, a dollars-and-cents issue.
But it's also about how this money is authorized.
When I was in the State Department, we actually
put out a pretty good geoeconomic theory of
the case in the president's first and I believe
only response to the Arab Spring: his May
2011 address, which really took full on the
revolutions across the Middle East.
Forwarded a pretty economic theory of the
case.
It was loan guarantees.
It was a billion-dollar debt swap for Egypt.
It was a set of enterprise funds for Tunisia
and Egypt that were modeled after what we
had done pretty successfully after the Soviet
Union.
Three years later, when I left the State Department,
those enterprise funds had yet to cut their
first check.
We were still arguing with ourselves, as an
administration, about how to spend this billion-dollar
debt swap, even as our Egyptian counterparts
in terms of who we were negotiating with had
since revolved.
And, you know, events have basically just
outpaced us.
So we-you know, we need the ability and the
wherewithal from Congress to be able to move
a little bit more quickly in how we spend
this money, separate and apart from how much
money we have to spend.
LINDSAY: Bob, anything you want to add to
that in terms of guidance to the next administration?
BLACKWILL: I guess-well, they're not-they're
not calling me all that often to ask.
(Laughter.)
But I'll just make one point, which Jen and
I emphasize in the book, which is that beginning
to use these economic tools for geopolitical
purposes is not a replacement for American
military might, which has to remain the most
stabilizing force in world order, in my opinion.
However, what we do argue is that we've become
too instinctively dependent on that instrument.
And one example of that-and I don't know if
there's anybody here who works on the Hill
or is watching who works on the Hill, but
have a look at what the hearings are on the
Hill and try to find a hearing that looks
at economic issues in the Foreign Relations
Committee.
They look at almost solely security questions.
This is not to argue, of course, they shouldn't
be looking at security questions.
But they don't think of economic means worth
exploring in public hearings to accomplish
some of our strategic objectives in the Middle
East, other than, as you said, Chairman, sanctions.
We understand what sanctions do.
We're very good at it in many ways.
But beyond sanctions, they simply don't think
in that way.
And what-you mentioned the next administration.
What we would like the next administration
to do is address this American asset-we have
the biggest economy in the world, with this
enormous economic power-address this asset
systematically; and think internally, how
do they organize themselves that, in NSC meetings-we've
all been in up here-that it actually comes
up, because usually the people who might address
that aren't in the room.
Aren't in the room.
So that's our dream, I guess is the word.
LINDSAY: Well, fair enough.
What I want to do now is bring our members
into the conversation.
Let me remind everybody that this meeting
is on the record.
I will also ask you to wait for the microphone
and speak directly into it.
I would also ask that you please stand, state
your name and affiliation.
And if people would keep their questions concise,
we can get everybody a chance to talk on this
provocative topic, we'll do that.
Let's start over here.
And Sam is going to come with a microphone
right behind you.
Q: Oh, you're over here, OK.
Snuck up on me.
Hi.
John Sullivan with George Mason University,
formerly with the Center for International
Private Enterprise.
Do you include U.S. foreign assistance in
your range of instruments that you look at?
It would seem to me logical to do it, not
that U.S. foreign assistance is often used
strategically.
But it could be.
HARRIS: Yes, we do, both economic and military.
Military is among the least interesting of
the bunch.
Only there because money's fungible, so military
assistance that we are giving is freeing up
budget space for the Egyptians or others that
they put to other ends.
And, yeah, I think we do need to have a real
conversation about the use of economic assistance
as a foreign policy tool, and what constitutes
an acceptable versus unacceptable use of,
you know, U.S. aid.
We also need to have a conversation about
how the world has changed, and what new tools
in the assistance space we should be considering.
I, for one, would like to see the U.S. begin
to look at instruments that would allow for
things like OPIC to take equity positions
in addition to debt.
That is a thing that's pretty routine and
happens as a regular course across our European
counterparts, not to mention the likes of
what the Chinese state-led policy banks are
throwing out at-you know, their going-out
strategies across Latin America and Africa.
That's something.
BLACKWILL: Can I just chime in and say-and
Jen mentioned Egypt earlier.
I like this question because it allows me
to give you this one, which is not rhetorical.
So what would you think will have the biggest
influence on the future of the Middle East:
the war in Yemen or the future of the Egyptian
economy?
And I think most of us would know the answer
to that.
And yet, we do pitifully little on the future
of the Egyptian economy.
Now, this isn't to suggest that economy is
our responsibility or that we can fix it.
But imagine a NSC meeting in which the subject
was how can we use American economic tools
comprehensively to bolster the economic future
of Egypt.
And I posit that that economic future will
be more decisive regarding American vital
national interests than most of what preoccupies
the administration and its predecessors, and
the media.
LINDSAY: Let's go over here to Professor Hollifield.
Q: Jim Hollifield, this year at the Wilson
Center, normally at the Tower Center at SMU
in Dallas.
How do you take into account sort of conventional
macroeconomic policy-exchange-rate policy,
interest-rate policy?
I mean, the U.S. does control the world's
reserve currency.
So how do you think about Bretton Woods?
And secondly, if we have stopped doing this-I
think we did it, certainly, in the '50s and
'60s-stopped doing this, why did we stop doing
it?
BLACKWILL: I think the question-I'm going
to turn this one over to Jen about because
it's-I think it's a terrific question.
The back half we really have struggled a lot
with, about.
We think we know what happened.
Why did it happen?
And we got into this a little bit on the trade
side, saying that the Congress and successive
administrations basically took any strategic
perspective out of the trade negotiations
through bureaucratic politics by having a
trade representative, taking it out of the
State Department, and so forth.
But over to Jen.
HARRIS: It's almost overdetermined.
So we trace this story about when the U.S.
sort of abandoned, you know, economics as
a first resort, and why, to about the end
of the Cold War, around Vietnam.
A couple things were going on at that time,
right?
One, there are-there's some bureaucratic politics,
as Bob mentioned-the USTR being pulled out
of the State Department and given its own
independent mandate.
It's also the first generation of economic
insecurity the country had experienced since
the Great Depression.
It was no longer clear that we had economic
carrots to be spending about on our geopolitical
agendas.
It was also the rise of the multinational
corporation, complete with a lobbying presence
here in Washington, that began to change some
of the discourse in Congress.
And you see that, you know, line up very well
in terms of the Congressional Record.
But to be a little provocative, I think one
theory about a lesser-appreciated factor has
more to do, actually, with what's going on
in the discipline of economics than foreign
policy.
Namely, it was the sort of-right the moment
when Keynes is going out of fashion and Milton
Friedman was coming into fashion.
And we happened to be up against an adversary,
in the Soviet Union, who made no particular
love of markets and had no particular use
for trade, and so every win for the United
States in terms of freeing trade and liberalizing
markets was also a win for us in geopolitical
terms.
And so perhaps it was no accident, actually,
that you saw this happy convergence between
the U.S.'s geopolitical interests and the
neoliberal economic orthodoxy that we began
seeing kind of rising toward its own.
And it worked pretty well for a while.
I think in the early years after the Cold
War, we faced no great adversary that required
us to rethink whether this happy alignment
still exists.
But now we're up against countries like China
and Russia that, once again, appear to have
no particular distinctions between state and
market, and are pretty comfortable exercising
power in economic terms.
And I think maybe it's time to ask whether
this happy alignment of our-of our security
and our economic sort of orthodoxies still
exists.
LINDSAY: Avis.
Eric (sp) will bring you a microphone.
Q: Avis Bohlen, retired Foreign Service officer,
former sometime colleague of Robert's.
I just-I had a few skeptical thoughts in-
BLACKWILL: Good.
Q: -reaction to what you said, and also a
question.
The first point, I think, Jen, you already
answered.
I was going to say that it's so much in our
ideology about free markets and non-interference.
And I would also add another point, that the
U.S. government has a lot less control over
the U.S. economy than a country like China
does over its economy.
So it just wasn't in our thinking, and not
just since Milton Friedman.
I mean, you know, we've been pushing free
trade since the Marshall Plan, as you-as you
mentioned.
So it's-I really question whether we're-you
know, what's the word?-ideologically set up-set
up to do this, or materially set up to do
it.
The second point is the balance of our interests.
You mentioned the example of the French not
being willing to give up selling the boats
to Russia.
Well, I mean, come on, that was tiresome.
The French are always tiresome, as we know.
(Laughter.)
But you know, they're a very important ally.
We're going to unleash the full power of the
United States economy to achieve this?
I mean, I think there is always a balance
of interests, and we have a lot of interests
around the world which are going to really
preclude this.
Third point is I think-
LINDSAY: Well, Avis, if I may, can I hold
you there so I let them have a chance to answer?
We have a lot of questions in the audience
I want to get to.
Q: Could I just mention that I think USAID
has always been a political instrument, and
I saw it in Eastern Europe in the-(off mic).
BLACKWILL: Thank you, Avis.
Nice to see you.
For those of you who don't know, Avis is one
of the premier experts on how tiresome the
French can be.
(Laughter.)
Day by day by day.
Enormous patience and skill on her part.
We don't suggest in the book that these instruments
be used crudely in every case.
But what we do say is that administrations,
in the kinds of meetings that you used to
routinely go to when you were here in policy
positions, is that they be at least raised
to see if they have potential.
So we don't want to hit an ant with a sledgehammer,
but we want to use these economic instruments
the way we routinely-routinely-use security
coercion, or at least imploration.
So that's that.
But the second is, more broadly, we used to-and
we have a chapter in the book on the history
of American use of this-we used to do this
with the people in the room, the counterparts
of the current Cabinet members, who just as
a matter of course thought this way.
And among-and I won't mention names here-but
among those who resist our policy prescriptions
are former secretaries of the Treasury, because,
as those of us who have worked in government
know, they tend to think of their business
as too important for foreign policy considerations.
Or the trade rep-I'm not speaking now about
any particular one of them-who tend to think,
and the Congress in particular tends to say,
oh, I know what these people at the State
Department are thinking; they want to trade
away American jobs for geopolitical purposes.
And so we used to know how to do this.
It wasn't questioned that this-these were
effective tools.
Sometimes they could be used badly, but that
they were available.
And that's, at least in our experience-which
covers certainly the period since the end
of the Cold War-not the case.
I'll give you one other example, which you'll
be, Avis, very familiar with.
What's the primary geopolitical action-successful
action in the 1990s?
It's Helmut Kohl going to Russia and writing
a check for German unification.
That-what better example of the use of an
economic instrument to pay for the departure
of the Red Army from East Germany and for
the apartments that were built for them and-a
beautiful, beautiful example.
Meanwhile, we were doing-trying to do enterprise
funds for-I was in the administration, in
the White House-for Eastern European transformation.
And we had no money.
So basically it's we had no money.
So we used to know how to do it, and we hope
we'll learn how to do it again.
LINDSAY: Mr. Paris.
Q: Jonathan Paris, former Middle East fellow
here and-I'm a former Middle East fellow and
currently a London-based analyst.
Just quickly on Egypt, of course the Egyptian
economy is important, but it'd be nice if
we could help them keep their planes from
falling out of the sky, because that really
impacts on their tourism.
But my question is on China.
China seems to have a good-a good deal going
in Africa, for instance.
They get a military base in Djibouti when
they put in $12 billion of infrastructure
in Ethiopia and Djibouti.
And what do we get stuck with?
We get stuck with doing all this counterterrorism
against Boko Haram in Mali.
So, you know, maybe the problem is they're
getting a free ride on the counterterrorism
and they get to get these chits, you know,
building ports, and then they get a whole
bunch of security benefits from all their
infrastructure.
BLACKWILL: I think Jen leaves for China tonight,
so maybe she should speak to that.
HARRIS: (Chuckles.)
Oh, I think you're absolutely right.
And I think you're beginning to see strands
of this bubble up in the context of the U.S.
general election.
It's not too dissimilar from some of the noises
that Donald Trump certainly has made in questioning
whether our allies are free-riding.
And China has been masterful in its ability
to parlay either the present reality of its
economic power or the projections of future
growth, which probably matter just as much,
into sort of its geopolitical throw-weight.
And so we could not agree more.
I think this is-you know, Britain has a project
to try to get-force Washington to begin to
wake up and confront what are not easy questions.
Absolutely these tools are, again, not to
be used lightly, nor are they without controversy
or costs.
And we try to be quite clear about that.
The problem is not that they cost something.
Of course they cost something.
But so too do every other form of statecraft,
especially our military.
BLACKWILL: And I'd say I just think it's a
good question about the Chinese in Africa.
They use the construction of soccer stadiums
as a geopolitical instrument.
And if you-I think they've now built over
30 of them.
And they are coincidentally in proximity to
the home villages of the president of the
country.
So this is pretty micro, but exactly what
you say.
Now, they can make mistakes, they can overdo
it, or so forth.
But look at the-at-which we do in the book-the
connection between Chinese economic assistance
to Africa and African votes at the U.N. on
issues we care about.
And-
HARRIS: Or recognition of Taiwan.
BLACKWILL: -or-yes, so-or recognition of Taiwan,
where there's a direct correlation.
So that, using assistance for their geopolitical
goals, is routine for them.
LINDSAY: Go to the back of the room.
Q: Yes, hi.
Thank you.
The name is Mercedes Fitchett with the Department
of Defense.
Back in 2003 after the Iraq invasion, where
we were building the whole coalition effort,
we actually used the-over $18 billion in U.S.
free construction projects as a stick and
a carrot for increasing the number of countries.
And I recall there was a huge battle with
France in terms of them being able to bid
on contracts, that they weren't part of the
coalition.
But did you all happen to take a look at what
we did with that-with that tool in terms of
growing the coalition in your book as a case
study?
BLACKWILL: Yeah.
I was the presidential envoy to Iraq when
you were-when you were working those, which
was-doesn't entirely explain our failure there
but is a major part of it.
Let me make this distinction.
And you were involved in it, so you'll have
much more details and maybe a definitive thought
different from mine.
When we were-and I was at the White House-we
were working our way through this, we didn't
think of those reconstruction efforts-first
of all, it's, of course, total chaos, as you
know and very little systematic thinking of
any kind in any case.
But insofar as we did think about it, we did
not think about the long-term future of Iraq
and how we might spend this money.
Most of the recommendations that came in that
we spent money in Iraq were from our military
commanders, who were trying-and of course
it was important that they try-to stabilize
wherever they were: in the western desert,
up north, and in the south near Basra.
So we didn't think about it in the kind of
geoeconomic terms that Jen and I discussed
in the book.
Secondly-now, I will display a prejudice-our
geoeconomic thinking was infected by the virus
of "one man and woman, one vote" and, quote,
"election objectives" in both Afghanistan
and Iraq.
And we became mesmerized by these election
processes at the expense of geoeconomic thinking.
So summing up, we spent our money-that money
very badly in-obviously in both those countries,
very badly.
And I think one of the reasons was that we
didn't, as Jen was urging and as we urge in
the book, we didn't think of these as tools
beyond the either pure development in a micro-area
or tools beyond bringing these people to democracy,
which, as we've seen, would have meant-since
it failed, of course, completely-would have
meant changing their entire culture and political
sociology.
So we didn't-
HARRIS: Just one postscript of optimism, I'll
have you know, which is that it's also true,
though, that we find that a lot of U.S. military
leaders are some of the most powerful surrogates
and champions for exactly the argument that
we're pushing.
As we describe in the book, when I was in
the early, tough stages of thinking through
Secretary Clinton's economic statecraft agenda,
I sat down with Admiral Mike Mullen and sort
of heard him riff on some of this.
And he gave more powerful expression to some
of these realities than anybody I had met
before or since.
And he just said, you know what, compare the
man hours, woman hours we, the U.S. military,
have spent thinking through the size and composition
of the Afghan National Security Forces to
the man/woman hours we have spent thinking
through a viable economic blueprint for that
country's future.
And until we get that balance closer to where
it should be, I think we should expect to,
you know, continue paying for it and influence-(inaudible).
BLACKWILL: Right, and Bob Gates, as you know,
in his book and in his public speeches urges
much more funds for the State Department for
essentially geoeconomic objectives.
And Leon Panetta did the same, and Ash Carter
does the same, so far essentially to deaf
ears in the Congress.
LINDSAY: OK, we have time for one more question.
Before I take it, I want to remind everybody
in the room this conversation has been on
the record.
I will also let people know that copies of
Bob and Jen's book are available for sale
at the back of the room.
Those joining us on Internet can-
BLACKWILL: So lock the doors.
(Laughter.)
LINDSAY: -always go on Amazon.com and other
e-retailers.
With that said, sir, you have the last question.
Q: Thanks very much.
Karan Bhatia with General Electric.
I was wondering if you could comment on a
thesis that I think may be a corollary to
what you're talking about, which is that the
intentions and the ultimate objectives of
a number of these other countries you referred
to are in fact more economic in their core.
So you look at One Belt, One Road, for instance,
in China, or you look at the position that
a number of European countries have taken
on sanctions, at the end of the day you sort
of look at those and you say, yeah, there's
a core strong economic element to it, advancing
their economic interest, whereas in the United
States we tend not to think about foreign
policy in those kinds of terms.
Would you agree with that?
Is that-is that a notion that sort of sits
well alongside the thesis of your book?
How do you see that idea?
BLACKWILL: Well, I think that-
Q: (Off-mic)-General Electric-
LINDSAY: I'm sorry?
Q: It's another question that I think should
have been asked, is (would ?) General Electric
have geopolitical ambitions-
LINDSAY: I'd like to hold that for another
meeting.
I'd like to give Bob and Jen an opportunity
to wrap up and then-
BLACKWILL: One Belt, One Road-well, we don't
know for sure, since the Chinese government
systematically lies about its strategic objectives,
as we know.
So we don't know for sure, but I do think
it has a strong economic core.
But I think at its base, it's geopolitical.
That is to say, if you look at the behavior
in the last 20 years, they systematically
build up dependencies, which they use for
their geopolitical purposes.
And they do it again and again and again.
And they remind people of these dependencies,
nations, when it matters.
So it's both.
But I think if you believe it's only-which
is what the Chinese, of course, say, which
is One Belt, One Road is only for the benefit
of the people of Asia, period.
Well, it has that dimension, if it produces
wealth and jobs and so forth.
But I can tell you I spend quite a bit of
time in Central Asia, and they-the people
in Central Asia do not take at face-value
that there are no geopolitical Chinese objectives
in this-in this policy.
LINDSAY: Any final word, Jen?
HARRIS: So I think you're-Karan, you're getting
to one of what was, I think, the hardest questions
for us in the book, which is, how do you know
it when you see it?
Countries rarely-sometimes they do helpfully
signpost pretty explicitly like the Saudis
did last week or as the Chinese have done
in conditioning certain investments by sovereign
wealth funds on Costa Rica's disavowal of
Taiwan.
There are pretty smoking-gun cases.
But more often and usually in the cases of
where it's most effective, it's much more
the stuff of correlation than direct causation.
And so it-but it's also the case that just
because there is some economic-you know, presence
of economic rationale doesn't negate also
the present of geopolitical rationale.
You know, all the better if there are twofers
and threefers, I think, for the Chinese.
But there are certain cases where, you know,
deals just don't make economic sense, and
yet they happen anyway.
And even in some of the IPOs that Chinese
state-owned enterprises have come into, you
know, New York and listed on our stock exchanges,
when you actually go through and read the
securities filings-I have done that-not the-you
know, the most fun weekend I've ever spent,
but they're very up-front about the fact that
these are companies that are owned by the
Chinese government, that there are certain
objectives that are political that will occasionally
trump-it's all kind of there black-and-white
when you sort of know what you're looking
for.
So, you know, I think there are certain cases
where you are going to just have to, you know,
initiate some kind of a smell test.
But just the sheer presence of economic motivation
doesn't negate, you know, the co-presence
of geopolitical rationales.
I just wanted to also add-
BLACKWILL: Can I just-
LINDSAY: I will-I will give the ambassador-I'll
give you the final word.
BLACKWILL: Well, no, no, just one last one,
which we can-another good example from China,
which is in this category Jen was mentioning,
notice the eerie coincidence that in the-in
the preliminaries to the visit of a Chinese
president to the United States for a summit
with our president, notice the eerie coincidence
of major Chinese purchases of Boeing aircraft.
They just do this routinely, and it's not
just Boeing.
It's Brazilian aircraft.
We go into lots of examples.
And I can assure you that in our-in the deliberations
of our highest councils of government, these
sorts of notions-and of course the private
sector for us, so it's not completely analogous-but
just thinking through what do we-what economic
instruments do we have in order to deal with
the rise of Chinese power or to deal with
China-sorry, Russia and their use, of course,
of pipeline politics, or to help foster our
national interests in the Middle East, what
are they?
And they just don't come up in the conversation.
LINDSAY: That is going to have to be the final
word on a very complex, timely, and deep subject.
However, the good news for everybody in the
room is that you can talk to Jen and Bob as
we wrap up.
And of course all of you are more than welcome
and encouraged to buy a copy of "War by Other
Means."
So please join me in thanking Bob and Jen
for a stimulating conversation.
(Applause.)
HARRIS: Thank you.
(END)